Steve Bannon the man who led Breitbart
news still conservative rage and created
a safe haven for white supremacists as
Donald Trump's chief strategist if
you're wondering what kind of power this
guy actually has you're not alone unlike
other White House jobs chief strategist
isn't a role that comes with a
well-defined set of responsibilities
chief strategists are generally playing
the long game when it comes to the
presidency their job is to look at the
big picture of a president's term his
legacy and of course his reelection the
chief strategist also has the ear of the
President on just about every issue he
wants to weigh in on it's a job that
requires an intimate connection with the
president and one that can shape not
just the decisions but the very identity
of her presidency historically speaking
the chief strategist job is relatively
new in 1933 Franklin Roosevelt became
the first president to have someone
serve as his counselor he relied on his
advisor Louis Howe so much that Hal
actually moved into the White House the
job didn't become an official one until
Nixon's presidency but there's not a lot
of information about the advisors who've
had the role and when there is it's not
always good
Nixon advisors HR Haldeman and John
Ehrlichman were known as the Berlin wall
of his presidency serving as gatekeepers
for the president they were also at the
center of the Watergate scandal
Ehrlichman created the White House
plumbers a group which was dedicated to
stopping leaks and investigating and
harassing Nixon's opponents both men
ended up being convicted of multiple
felony charges and more recently there
was karl rove george w bush's right-hand
man rove held enormous influence over
the president advising him on domestic
and foreign policy as well as handling
political outreach for the white house
he got a divided Congress and a
skeptical American public to support the
US invasion of Iraq Rove was part of the
White House rock group which played on
post 9/11 fears and pushed the false
claim that Iraq had weapons of mass
destruction
as for Steve bannon's role in shaping a
trump presidency only time will tell
what he has in store for us
[Music]